after a highly successful first series
Netflix are following up on the show's
ascension with Sabrina's very own
Christmas special throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about a mid Winter's
Tale as well as how it could tie in to
the main season there will be spoilers
here so those who don't want to know the
show's ending should turn off now but
for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to do the seasonal special opens on
Sabrina as a child saying that she
wishes that she could see her mother as
a gift from Santa we then flash-forward
to one week before Christmas and joined
Sabrina platinum hair and all saying of
Christmas decorations it feels like
something pulled straight out of the
perfect Christmas but Sabrina is still
quite sad and low about the holiday
Sabrina is clearly missing Harvey so
it's great that we get some finality on
who she has chosen since the last season
left on a bit of a cliffhanger she
realizes that she needs to give her
friends space to adjust to the fact that
she is a witch but is a bit lost on the
best way to handle her friendships with
them going forward after seeing her
mother in limbo in the prior season
Sabrina realizes that she wishes to
reach out to her and ask for advice on
how to handle the situation she too
wants to free her mother from the
purgatory and Sabrina holds a séance to
contact her Sabrina's connection is
broken before she gets to hear anything
meaningful from her mother and Zelda
discovers what they are doing
Zelda stops the seance as apparently
it's okay to kidnap babies but not to
contact your mother anyway a couple of
spirits come through during the ritual
as the Yule Log fire that was put there
to protect the house is put out by madam
ward well and this quickly becomes a
villain of the week episode I got really
bad flashbacks to the possession of
Hannah grace and the ghosts on even the
scariest part Sabrina's friend Susie is
nearly made into an elf figure and
there's a really creepy vibe to the
entire episode that definitely brought
out the more sinister side of Santa
everything gets wrapped up pretty neatly
with the ghosts aku lights being sent
back to where they came from after the
family make contact with them other
kryla she wishes to take the baby with
her but Sabrina's mother appears and
comes up with a morality test in order
to determine who should look after the
baby that's Ella kidnapped they trick
Riley and are deemed worthy to still
keep the baby even though they're the
kind of people who think it's okay to
kidnap a baby that's not the end of
growler though and she rescues Susie
from living the rest of her life as a
mannequin and the Spellman's trick
Susie's father into thinking his
daughter's disappearance was all the
dream
Zelda decides to return the baby as she
will forever be in danger with them
Sabrina's mother returns once more and
say that she's happy that Sabrina lives
with a family that loves her however she
does not think that Sabrina and Harvey's
relationship is a good idea and warns
her off this dog path we learned that
her and finished business that is
keeping her in limbo it's the worry of
her daughter and she returns they're out
there the swords close even with all
this though Sabrina clearly is taking a
step towards being a good person as she
helps Harvey's father's alcoholism
Harvey states that he wishes she would
stop casting magic spells on him and
around him but does appreciate it even
though he returns the gift that Sabrina
gave him the big pointer to take from
this episode is that many people
including myself believe that Sabrina
would be a villain after the end of the
first season but this clearly showcases
that she is still a good person and I
believe that going forward that this
duality will cause problems between her
and the forces of evil that she has now
become aligned with the show ends with
demon men coming out of the mines and
this is a tease towards season two of
the show which returns in April two
thousand nineteen it's pretty difficult
to decipher what this means but they
could be seen as the satanic three wise
men here to ruin Christmas what will
happen is still up in the air but I'm
definitely excited to see the show
return after watching the trailer at the
end of the episode so what are your
thoughts on the Sabrina Christmas
special and where do you hope to see the
show going in season two comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of this week's big movie
Aquaman which will be linked at the end
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to Definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]